can I show you something hell yeah well
I recorded this on my phone like as a
voice note and I sent it to my boy
Oliver and he made this whole beat
around it oh yeah bro you gotta sing too
bro
[Music]
[Applause]
all these [__] I'm so sick of them
but I still got a whole lot of dick for
him and I will tell no I can't kick with
them tell them no smoke guys get on I
ain't feeling no I say baby I need me a
criminal she don't keep the Glock in the
purse and get rid of it
it's a cold we'll be living even my mama
told me don't trust these [__] money
sticking to my ties driving on the rotor
[__] I can't live on Vine I throw it
in the ditches right on it so cold but
we living they gonna use you for mileage
I just need some distance
bro yes that was great that's crazy